hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast mapping cerebellum to
forebrain connectivity using
optogenetics and functional magnetic
resonance imaging presented by dr. paul
matthews an investigator at La biomed an
assistant professor of neurology at UCLA
i'm susie valdez of lab routes and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
routes
lab routes is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I want to
remind everyone that today's event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of the screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the help desk
button located on the promotional board
at the bottom center of your screen or
use that ask a question box to let us
know you're having a problem the
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credit tab located on the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process for obtaining more
credits please join me now in welcoming
our presenter dr. Paul Matthews I will
now turn the presentation over to him
welcome sir
Thanks so I'm definitely excited to talk
to you today thank you for inviting me
to speak at this lab roots neuroscience
event I'll be telling you a bit about a
methodological approach that we've used
to begin to map cerebellum to floor
brain connections the talk today will
sort of follow this general outline I'm
going to tell you a bit about and remind
you of the cerebellar data being
connectivity I want to give you a little
bit of a background as to some of the
current limits and our understanding of
cerebellar connectivity and function
especially in terms
connections to the forebrain and how it
might be involved in a higher-order
brain function I'll tell you a bit about
our recently published work that shows
how we can utilize an approach to map
region specific connectivity between the
cerebellum and forebrain by combining
optogenetics
and functional red resonance magnetic
imaging and then at the very end I'll
tell you a little bit about how we're
interested in extending this approach to
understand the links between disruptions
and connectivity of potentially
psychiatric illness so to start with
here's sort of an obligate image of the
cerebellum I wanted to show you this in
particular so that you could have some
reference between both the human brain
and that of the rodent brain today's
talk will focus on experiments that were
conducted in the mouse brain so the
cerebellum is located just dorsal of the
brainstem there are a number of
anatomical subdivisions that can be
described including the anterior and
posterior lobes as well as a central
vernal region if we look at the ventral
view we can see that there's also this
sort of evolutionarily old
flocculonodular lobe the cerebellum can
be further broken down into a number of
others anatomical subdivisions on the
right here you can see a cartoon of a
human cerebellum and on the left that of
a rodent in this case particularly a rat
the cerebellum from rostral to caudal
which is top to bottom and this can be
divided across nine different folia and
this is within the vernal region we can
from medial to lateral II divided it up
into the vermis para vermis and
hemispheres and then we can continue to
in least within the hemispheres create a
defying anatomical subdivisions
including the lateral simplex sell us
their cruise 1 cruise to the para medial
lobule as well as the pair of oculus etc
now the within the cerebellum is
basically composed within all of these
anatomical regions a number of folio or
invaginations as you can see here that
evolutionarily increase as you go from
the wrap which you see in the top left
down to the human in the bottom right
within each of these folios similar to
what you see in the the neocortex or the
cerebral cortex that these that the
cortical structure of the cerebellum is
composed of a repeating motif of
specific neurons that are interconnected
and ways in which we have a pretty good
idea of the major players in this
although there are a few others our
granule cells the molecular layer inter
neurons as well as probably the most
well known neurons in the cerebellum
that are the Purkinje neurons this
entire structure here which is composed
inside the what's called the cerebellar
cortex receives inputs via two different
pathways specifically that of the mossy
fiber pathway which sees projections
from a number of regions including the
cerebral cortex stimuli i--there's
reticular formation in spinal cord an
information regarding sensory and
proprioceptive information is brought
into the cerebellum via this pathway the
other major input into the cerebellum is
via the climbing fiber pathway which
originates in the inferior olive and
it's thought to bring in signals that
generate changes within this overall
circuit that are necessary for learning
the Purkinje neurons send projections
down and out to the deep cerebellar
nuclei which can be further divided into
the vestigial interposed and dentate
which you can see here and then
color-matched all the way to the left in
this anatomical version of a coronal
slice of the cerebellum and then
ultimately the deep cerebellar nuclei
are except for some vestibular regions
of the cerebellum the only projection
only areas that project out of the servo
so the cerebellum can sort of grossly at
this point be subdivided based on its
inputs and outputs that
is there is there are regions to on the
lateral edge of the cerebellum that send
and receive projections primarily
through the thalamus to regions of the
floor brain and this composes the
cerebrum cerebellum the medial third of
the cerebellum sends and receives
sensory and motor information and sends
projections through descending tracts to
the spinal cord and is often called the
spinocerebellar and then you have the
vestibular cerebellum which communicates
with different regions of the vestibular
areas including the vestibular nuclei
the cerebellum does appear to have a
topographical representation of the body
at least multiple of these is similar to
what we see in both the sensory and
motor cerebral cortices in the cerebrum
however we don't have a real clear
understanding and have not been able to
further delineate functional regions of
the cerebellum to the point in which we
can identify specific visual potentially
cognitive or speech regions of the
cerebellum and of course the major
question is is there really further
evidence for these functional
subdivisions and how might we begin to
determine whether there are these
functional subdivisions well one way to
do that in the way we've often done that
within the cerebral cortexes is to begin
to define both the inputs as well as the
outputs now the cerebellum has some
projections that go towards the cerebrum
and the classical view of this is that
it's an open that is that the cerebro
cerebellar loop consists of projections
mainly from cortical structures like the
motor parietal cingulate print fordham
prefrontal cortices that project motor
sensory and cognitive information to the
pons and at the pons then projects to
the cerebellum by up onto the cerebellar
pathway and then back through the
ventral lateral thalamus to in
particular the motor court
in which this information really
provides a substrate for integrating the
information that's needed by the primary
motor cortex for the generation and
control movement and really a lot of
what we know about the cerebellum and
given what we know about diseases of the
Sarah Bohm we that it disrupts motor
behavior however a lot a number of
research studies over the last 20 to 30
years have really broaden our
understanding of what the cerebellum
might what its function might be this is
certainly the case with research that
has been pioneered by jeremy Schmo man
who is one of the keynote speakers in
this series so what is there what
evidence is there that the cerebellum
might contribute in some fashion to a
more a more broad and diverse set of
behaviors other than just motor function
which is suggested by this type of
cerebral cerebellar loop
well the pioneering work by striking
colleagues have shown that there are a
number of projections by it
predominantly regions in the dentate
part of the cerebellar nuclei to a
number of regions that are not only
motor but also non motor in function
including regions of the brain like the
inferior parietal cortex and the
prefrontal cortex further studies have
also shown that there are projections to
the striatum as well as the hypothalamus
and the VTA unfortunately for the most
part the majority of these studies have
not shown any particular projections all
the way back up to the cerebellar cortex
and so it's still unknown in terms of
what in terms of what the functional
distribution of areas are within the
cerebral cortex and even within the
dentate itself and part of this has to
do with limitations in the methods that
have been used to do these types of
tracings and that is basically using
retrograde trance in Aptech methods and
the problem here is is that oftentimes
what one would has to do is is you
a priori decisions and turns that the
regions in which they'll inject these
retrograde dyes basically making a
decision as to where to try to trace
back into the cerebellum that the
cerebellum projects to what would
ultimately like to be able to do is is
to identify this is to do it in the
reverse direction that is identify a
specific region in the cerebellum and
look forward as to where it is that it
connects to unfortunately even with new
methods that we have for track tracing
which we can jump maybe one synapse
we're unable to to fully define and map
out the different projections of
discrete anatomical sub regions of the
cerebellum in particular within the
cerebellar cortex so are these
projections functional
electrophysiological approaches have
further validated that these projections
do have functional relevance in that a
number of studies have shown that by
modulating activity predominantly within
the cerebellar nuclei that you can
record changes in activity by modulating
regions of the cerebellum however still
we don't have a clear understanding of
what these direct or indirect pathways
are and in large part we don't know
which parts specifically of the
cerebellum project to what array of
regions down across the forebrain now
imaging networks suggest that there is a
diversity in these projections and that
the cerebellum interacts significantly
with different parts of the forebrain so
imaging using resting-state magnetic
resonance imaging has defined what are
concurrent termed controlled networks
these are networks interconnected brain
regions that show correlation in
activity during some type of brain state
such as the salience network the
executive control Network and a default
mode Network now the cerebellum has been
found to participate across a number of
these different control networks
including exactly
executive control Network you can see
the right and left as there is an
asymmetry in these control networks and
that it participates within the default
load the salience and the sensorimotor
Network and what's also interesting here
is this that it's not the entire
cerebellum but discrete regions of the
cerebellum that appear to be involved in
different types of control networks what
you see on the right here are structural
scans of a hoard of horizontal images of
the cerebellum and each of these colored
areas indicates that part of the brain
is involved in a particular control
network which is indicated on the left
and you can see that there are discrete
regions of the cortex that are involved
in specific control networks suggesting
that different areas of the cerebellum
are involved in specific functional
aspects of behavior and this has been
further illustrated by work by Yale and
and Buckner that looked again using
resting-state correlations to show that
different areas of the cerebellar cortex
have correlational activity with a wide
variety of regions across the entire
cerebrum work by jeremy Schmo - i
mentioned before is to keep one of the
keynote speakers for this symposia has
spent quite a lot of time and effort in
trying to in basically championing a
somewhat becoming more appreciated fact
that the cerebellum is likely
contributing to more than just the motor
control domain and a major challenge in
this has been that non motor behavior
deficits that he has been able to define
with in-service cerebellar disorders are
oftentimes much less obvious and
intrusive than motor deficits and habit
in most cases that are often ignored but
with some stringent tests one can and
have found that there are major domains
within
non-motor ere at Mont non-motor domains
in which the cerebellum appears to be in
control of and this contributing to and
that includes behaviors and domains
including the attentional control
emotional control autism spectrum
psychosis spectrum and social skill set
and it's likely that all of that the way
that the cerebellum is contributing
across this diverse domain this diverse
set of domains is through interactions
with the fore brain which suggests that
we really do need to understand and
define what are the functional regions
of the cerebellum that project to the
floor brain and what is the differences
that exist across these different
functional domains so ultimately what
I'm really interested in is what types
of methods can we use to specifically
delineate from any given region within
the cerebellar cortex such as medial
crews one what is the array of areas
within the forebrain that it
functionally connects to that it
interacts with that it has influence on
so one of the challenges with this is is
basically do the fact that Purkinje
neurons are inhibitory so one can't go
into the cerebellar cortex stick an
electrode stimulate and then record
downstream as the ultimate effect of
those of that stimulation causes
inhibition of the deep cerebellar nuclei
of course this inhibition is known to
cause a biphasic response which I'll
actually show you in a minute and it's
hard to utilize that in some senses as a
way to properly drive out put from the
cerebellar cortex in order to understand
what are the outputs regions that are
modulated so in order to control
specific regions of the cerebellum we've
decided to take an off to genetic
approach that takes microbial opsins
that can transduce a change in
neural activity within the neurons in
particular either channelrhodopsin-2 or
arch and we can use some genetic tricks
to basically put them specifically into
the Purkinje neurons in order to
modulate their activity and in this case
I'm basically using a strategy where we
use in l7 or PCP to create driving the
expression of either channelrhodopsin-2
fused with yet yfp here on the right or
l7 crea driving the expression of arch
and inhibitory opsin on the right and of
course if we shine light onto these
molecules what we're able to do is cause
a change in in the neurons activity that
we could ultimately use to examine their
effects on downstream areas and what you
see on the right here is just some
individual single cell recordings in an
in vitro slice preparation in which we
show that by shining light on to perk
engine your ons we can either on the
Left four neurons expressing
channelrhodopsin to increase their
activity or on the right if we shine
light on two neurons expressing right
that we get a pause and activity what
happens in the live animal when we do
this so what we can do is is we can use
a lot of recording electrodes and put
them into the brain and a weight
behaving animal shine late light onto
the Purkinje neurons expressing either
arch or general dobson and see how it
changes activity there and of course we
see predictable changes that is with
such channelrhodopsin-2 which is an
excitatory auxin we get an increase in
spiking and in arch we get a pause and
activity each of these lines on the top
is an action potential and so this is an
example trace and below is a peri
stimulus time histogram showing the
overall activity of 50-plus neurons what
we really were ultimately interested in
it was to determine how modulating the
Purkinje neurons up the cerebellar
cortex would influence those neurons
down in the syrup in the cerebellar
nuclei because ultimately what we wanted
was a method for driving a consistent
reliable output of the cerebellum from
the cerebellar cortex that we could then
investigate the rest of the forebrain
with and so what we did was we can
report core again here from now the
cerebellar nuclei shine light on the
Purkinje neurons and in animals that
express channelrhodopsin
- we get a an expected pause in their
activity during the light pulse and a
big rebound excitation of subsequently
for the arch expressing my suik an see
that there's a a relatively time-locked
burst in activity that increases quite
significantly and that this increase in
activity is correlated right with the
timing of our laser light pulse and
we've seen this even for brief pulses 10
of 10 in 25 milliseconds long so what we
wanted what we did was this we took this
particular approach in terms of using
arch to drive activity from specific
regions of the cerebellar cortex to
drive output through the cerebellar
nuclei and then the question was how do
we detect and determine which regions of
the forebrain are modulated by this
activity we could use electrodes but
then again we'd have to make a priority
decisions on exactly where to stick
those electrodes of course we have these
large electrode arrays but still only
were able to record for maybe a couple
of brain regions at a time and what we
really wanted was a way to in a brain
wide assay to examine which of the
regions downstream are modulated by this
particular region of the cerebellar
cortex so what we've done is is we have
utilized this optogenetic approach and
the image above is just a chroma slice
of the cerebellum and Purkinje neurons
in green expressing the arch protein and
then below we've just shown that we can
implant a fiber-optic cannula into the
brain and what we've done is we've
paired this to drive out put from the
cerebellum with functional magnetic
resonance imaging which allows us to
observe using changes in blood
oxygenation level as a proxy
for changes in neuronal activity we can
monitor what the changes are across the
entire forebrain are in response to
stimulation using optogenetics of a
discrete region of the cerebellar cortex
so this is what we've done
what were you see here and as a function
of the imaging and the of the imaging
itself we needed to put the optic fiber
in horizontally oftentimes most people
will put it in vertically but there is a
a coil that has to sit on top of the Cir
of the mouse's head while we do this
imaging and you can see that we can
observe where the fiber was located in
its implantation site here in this
histological preparation as well as
within this structural scan from an MRI
image that was taken what we did then
was is to use a pulse of light that is
of some frequency and so we pause the
Kinji neurons driving output from the
cerebellum at some frequency so experts
at 50 Hertz do the cycle and we did it
on/off on/off and then we recorded the
bold signals during the on in the often
compared them such that we could then
determine which regions would across the
forebrain in particular were modulated
by this specific region of the
cerebellar cortex and in particular we
implanted it into a four limb region of
the cerebellum that we had previously
shown that if we shined light onto it we
could drive the specific motor
behavioral output so results from this
type of experiment here are shown on the
right what you can see on the top are
basically structural scans with an
anatomical atlas outlined on top and
then colored on top of that are regions
in which the bold signal or we can talk
about it as being the neural activity
within it are significantly modulated by
light pulses in the cerebellar cortex
and in this case I did it at five Hertz
ten Hertz and 20 Hertz because we
weren't exactly sure as to what
frequency would best drive output
through the cerebellum what we found is
this that actually low frequency versus
high frequency drives a significant
output from the cerebellar cortex that
can be detected both at the level of the
thalamus which you can see on the bottom
left image of the brain and then at five
Hertz but not ten and twenty Hertz we
can see activation in the motor cortex
which you can see illustrated by that
arrow at the bottom here we're basically
looking at the percent old change of the
activated voxels within the motor cortex
itself and you can see that we see a
relatively we can detect changes in bold
signal at five Hertz but we don't really
see any significant activation across
the ten and twenty Hertz that is at
least prolonged across the entire
stimulation the light stimulation so
what just to clarify in terms of what's
in these graphs here at the bottom the
green bar indicates the time periods
over which the light stimulus is on in
red are the animals that Express arch
that were stimulated and in black are
animals that were stimulated by the
light but did not express the light
mooney beutifull opsin we then wanted to
know what the actual effects were at a
single cell and with Spike time
resolution within these this motor
cortex brain region and so we then
utilized customizable silicon micro
probes that were pioneered in ceteris
mas Benitez lab at UCLA and we basically
took these probes that have multiple
electrodes up to 128 128 probes that we
used and we implanted them into the
motor cortex while we again modulated
the specific cerebellar drove output of
the cerebellar cortex using the option
etic approach
and which you can see our results to
this on the right at the five ten and
twenty Hertz in the motor cortex
specifically and so we implanted into
the motor cortex the top graphs each row
is a single cell and the changing colors
indicate the fold change in the firing
rate into blue is a decrease in firing
rate over baseline and red is an
increase in firing rate over baseline
what you can see in the summary plots
below is this for all the act the
excited cells in red that there is a
prolonged increase in the spiking rate
over the entire period shown in agreed
by the green bar in its action potential
rate which we don't see in the ten and
twenty Hertz and it's likely that this
is the reason even though there may be a
burst of activity or a response in the
very beginning that is unable to
contribute well enough to a change in
the bold signal so we believe that lower
frequencies are better at least in terms
of this tool for driving significant
activity down into the motor cortex we
also are using relatively oh and we also
had and this actually further summarizes
what we saw within the
electrophysiological study in that for
the five Hertz stimulation we saw almost
80 to 90 percent of cells modulated in
some fashion either excited inhibited or
showed a mixed response well at ten and
twenty we showed we found less than
fifty percent and this is further
summarized on the right in that our what
we also observed was that the sustained
response was very different between the
five Hertz compared to the ten and
twenty Hertz in which if you look on the
left here in the average excited change
fold change in activity that there's
this hump of red demonstrating or
illustrating a increase in change in
activity that continues throughout the
entire light pulse
where
in the 10 and 20 Hertz this is not
really a parent we wanted to take a look
at whether the pulse length or the
frequency itself was the biggest driver
in this difference and so we tested a
few different frequencies with different
duty cycles that is different durations
of the light pulse itself and so we
basically tried five Hertz 25
millisecond long pulses and so this 5
Hertz 25 milliseconds was provided to
the cerebellar cortex for an entire 30
seconds this should be clear and then we
tried 20 Hertz of 25 milliseconds and
then compared it to what we had already
seen in terms of the 5 Hertz and 100
milliseconds
and we found that really the that the
duration of the pulse also had a
significant effect on the amount of
activation or modulation that we saw in
the motor cortex we also wanted to test
whether we could drop the light
intensity we did find that we did need
to use 143 milliwatts which is about a
20 mil power out of the tip of the fiber
and if we did a back calculation this
does indicate that we are on this does
suggest we are still only activating on
average around a few hundred Purkinje
neurons this further illustrates that
the higher intensity stimulation is
necessary to significantly drive output
downstream again I want to illustrate
that this is not we're not trying to
show what a physiological range is what
we're trying to do is is determine a
parameter space that will provide us the
sets of frequencies or the frequency
that we would best observe changes in
downstream activity in order to use this
as a mapping tool which is what we've
done here so we use the 5 Hertz 143 ml a
lot stimulation
this was across 1/32 on 32nd off and we
control and we compared this in arch
expressing versus control and what you
see here is a set of structural scans
from rostral at the top to caudal on the
bottom here going from left to right and
down and each of the in within each of
these panels you can see significantly
activated voxels in specific regions
across the brain and so what we found
was is that for this one discrete region
of the cerebellum cerebellum cortex that
we could drive functional activation in
multiple regions across the brain and
here's just a summary table of some of
the regions that we found activated
including places like the thalamus the
hippocampus particular formation motor
cortex anterior cingulate cortex we saw
a little to no activation in places like
the basal ganglia and triangle cortex
and insular cortex and should be noted
that the basal ganglia has been at least
implicated in connectivity with the
cerebellum however it may just be that
there's one particular functional region
does not project strongly to that area
and it's really that key question as to
what are the parts of the cerebellar
cortex that project any of these given
regions that is a major question that we
have and we think that this approach
might be able to answer to examine some
of these different brain regions in
particular so we saw modulation of
downstream sites in the thalamus the
retro selenium cortex the campus as well
as the motor cortex here we can we show
the change in bold signals specifically
within activated voxels only within
those regions of the brain that are
illustrated across the top here so you
have basically a structural scan
illustrating the brain region and then
on top of that the mask that we use to
pinpoint which we're within our scanning
image that we are looking at changes in
what we're looking for significantly
activated voxels we can
then drop recording electrodes into
these same regions and look to see
whether there are differences in the way
that the cerebellum modulates activity
in each of these regions so the next
level question really is is for this
particular region of the cerebellar
cortex how exactly does it modulate
downstream activity at the single cell
level and we can even detect not only
excitable excitation but also in
addition which to some degree is a bit
of a challenge using fMRI approaches and
what you can see down across the bottom
here is and we're plotting now the
change in rate normalized to the
baseline so that we can compare across
these four different regions the change
in activity during the 30 second light
pulse laser pulse of 5 Hertz 134 millaa
millaa watts per millimeter squared and
you can see that there is a diversity in
the types of influence the cerebellar
cortex has on these regions within the
thalamus it appears that for the most
part it is a relatively sustained
response whereas regions like the motor
cortex actually appear to have a more
distributed set of activity in which
only at different time points across the
stimulation are they active we further
validated this approach utilizing C foss
staining which is a marker for changes
in really act activation of neurons and
basically what we looked at were
specifically in the motor cortex as well
as in this case the anterior cingulate
cortex and we found that there were
significant increases and the mice that
expressed arch that were stimulated
versus those mice that did not express
arch that were stimulated and that's
shown here on the right each of these
dots here basically is an individual
neuron that is expressing the C faust
protein and you can see that there are
much more of them in the top which is
the arch expressing versus the bottom
which is the non arch expressing our
controls and then this is further
summarized in the plot below
so hopefully what you will take home or
stay where you are
given the digital nature of this talk is
that brief synchronous pre contain your
own pauses can drive cerebellar output
via the cerebellar nuclei and can be
used to then investigate downstream
brain regions and discreetly modulating
the in this case the forelimb region the
cerebellum results in modulation across
not just a few but quite a diverse array
of flora mid brain regions some of which
may be due to indirect activity due to
the proprioceptive input from the fore
limb movements and that the combination
of optogenetics fMRI and the
multi-electrode array recordings can
really be used as a platform to provide
brain wide mapping of cerebellar
projections and our goal is to really
begin to understand and to utilize this
approach a little bit further to examine
what happens to this connectivity in
this communication between the
cerebellum in disease in which there are
changes within these connectivities and
to define what those changes are and
potentially to be able to relate them to
specific disease states and of course
one can utilize not only optogenetics
but one can also utilize chemo genetics
to specifically modify the activity
within these specific regions and we can
use not only functional magnetic
resonance imaging but resting-state
magnetic magnetic resting state
functional magnetic resonance imaging to
begin to assess how there are how
perturbations in this in the cerebellar
cortex i there is a function of chemo
genetics optogenetics or even genetic
manipulations and mouse models of
disease to give us a better sense as to
which regions within the
for brain are being disrupted and then
potentially utilized that information as
targets for therapeutics and I do want
to end with a list of diseases that have
at least implicated the cerebellum in
potentially being either affected or
being responsible for so it's a little
bit of a chicken or the eggs a question
here and whether the overall
[Music]
pathogenesis of the disease causes
changes in the cerebellum or whether
disease processes in the cerebellum
actually generate some of the symptom
ology of the disease and its approaches
like the ones that I've described that
it would allow us to do and look
longitudinally across mouse models of
disease to begin to assess where and
which of the connect connections and
areas of the brain are being perturbed
first and giving us a better sense as to
whether it is the cerebellum that is
driving a major it is contributing a
major affect to the overall symptom
ology within diseases such as autism
spectrum disorders gets a fenner schizo
friend yet it's that true so I'd like to
really thank my new lab I've been in
this job for about two years and the
work that I just showed you was
published in the journal neural image
and was accepted just last week I really
like to thank my technician Carlos
Sanchez who helped to pioneer in my lab
doing the electrophysiological
multi-electrode array recordings and I
certainly want to thank my partner in
crime Katrina Chow who we worked on the
paper together and then for all of the
help that Neal Harris as well as Tom
Otis contributed to the work and also
I'd like to thanks the chairs must
Benitez for providing both resources as
well as technical help with a multi
electrode arrays thank you
and Thank You dr. Matthews for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type that question
into the box that appears on the screen
and click the send button will answer as
many questions as we have time for so
let's take a look at our incoming
questions from our audience members now
dr. Matthews what advantages does the Oh
F MRI approach provide compared to tract
tracing methods that have been
previously used to show cerebellum - for
brain connectivity yes so thank you yeah
so the O fMRI which is off to genetic
functional magnetic resonance imaging so
we keep putting more of these letters
together or resting-state etc so the
major advantage here is is that we're
going from a cerebellum to forebrain
rather than from a priori decisions
downstream and trying to track them all
the way back up into the cerebellum so
most of the classical tract tracing
methods have used trans synaptic methods
that basically trace retrograde lis that
is from the source back to from the
target back to the source so injections
within the prefrontal cortex are then
mapped all the way back or injected and
then mapped all the way back to the
cerebellum this approach allows us to
move from the forward direction in which
we can manipulate discrete regions of
the cerebellum we can use small optic
fibers 100 200 micrometer 's in diameter
and affect only small areas of the
cerebellum and we've calculated on the
order of a few hundred Purkinje neurons
and then we can do a brain wide assay
which is also something that's limited
within their current tract tracing
methods to see what regions are
modulated and this is not dependent upon
in this is not dependent upon single on
issues related to the number
synapses there are of course some new
approaches that allow for anterograde
track tracing and those are going to be
quite powerful however they are still
limited to jumping basically a single
synapse and until they're capable of
jumping multiple synapses like some of
the retrograde tracers are we're gonna
have to find other approaches to map out
especially within the cerebellar cortex
which is sending projections from kindy
neurons to the cerebellar nuclei to in
most cases the thalamus and then out to
other brain regions thank you for that
dr. Matthews here's our second question
where were there any surprising regions
of the forebrain activated by
stimulation of the cerebellar cortex so
yeah we there were a few that we didn't
completely anticipate maybe the
hippocampus and probably the anterior
cingulate cortex the hippocampus at
least the dorsal hippocampus seemed
significantly activated
there has been some indication from the
lab of issue on salties that there that
there that one can modulate activity in
the hippocampus with stimulation in the
cerebellar cortex but the direct
pathways between the cerebellum and the
hippocampus aren't known I think that
there are certainly some people out
there looking at that I think that it's
pretty interesting that a putative sort
of non motor area like the anterior
cingulate cortex is modulated here and
it certainly would be interesting to
begin to probe using these multi
electrode arrays and some behavioral
paradigms to begin to understand what
that communication might be for thank
you for that and I want to remind
audience members today that any
questions not asked can be asked and we
will answer them via email
from the presenter dr. Matthews thank
you so much for today
would you like to provide any closing
remarks for the audience no I don't
think so okay I'd like to once again
thank dr. Matthews for his presentation
and I'd also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible we before we go I want to
remind everyone that today's webcast
will be available on demand through June
2018 you'll receive an email from lab
roots letting you know that the webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thank
you for joining us we hope to see you
again soon
bye bye thank you